see how we can find the distance between
two
points let this be our number line where
we have numbers from minus1 to 6 and
these are two points on the number line
what is the distance between point A and
B one way in which we can figure out the
distance is by counting the number of
units in between A and B There are four
units 1 2 3 and four it means that the
distance between A and B is 4 units but
this method is tedious if there are many
units in between which tells us that we
have to look for an easier way to find
the
distance how do we find the distance
between points A and B here look at the
numbers under points A and B it's 1 and
five the distance between points A and B
equal absolute value of 5 - 1 which
equals 4 there are a few things we
learned here first the distance between
A and B is written like this D and then
AB in
Brackets the distance is the absolute
value of the difference between the end
points of segment
AB here the end points are five and 1
remember it's the absolute value of the
difference
so it can also be written as absolute
value of 1 - 5 the absolute value
ignores the sign of the number so even
absolute value of 1 - 5 will equal
4 but it is always a good practice to
subtract the smaller number from the
larger
number we should also know that the
distance between points A and B is the
same as length of segment AB so length
of segment AB in this example is 4 units
here's another example this time we have
to find the distance between points C
and D the first thing you should do is
look at the end points of the segment
the end points of the segments are 2 and
minus 2 so the distance between the
points C and D will be absolute value of
2 -
-2 2 - -2 is 4 four and absolute value
of four is four the length of segment CD
is 4 units in the next video we will
understand this better with the help of
coordinate
[Music]
axis